Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
We've be getting all kinds of Deadpool
3 reveals from Marvel
Like we see Deadpool versus Wolverine
and now because a big part of the movie
is and bringing back
all the classic X-Men actors
to play versions of their characters
again.
Elizabeth Olsen Also coming back
is another version of her Scarlet Witch
for some House of M Easter Eggs.
in. As part of all this,
it looks like we're actually
going to get a full on Scarlet
Witch versus Phoenix fight.
Oh, Wow. Oh, my God.
wow, wow, wow, wow.
so now what we see is For those of you
who have always wondered
who would win in a fight
if they actually
went up against each other.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're still in the middle
of Secret Invasion episodes.
That'll end pretty soon,
but then we'll be getting Loki season
three later this year too.
So there's a bunch of big Marvel stuff
coming up.
a big part of Deadpool
three will crossover with the events
of Loki Season two, but it'll be happening
after the events of Loki.
Season two
During
the movie, Deadpool is using cable's time
travel device to jump around
cleaning up different timelines
as he jokes
about at the end of Deadpool two.
And that gets him on the TVA's prune list.
Mobius has agents come after him
there'll be a bunch of TVA characters
from the Loki series in Deadpool
three in at some point in the movie.
Deadpool is going to travel to.
A universe is meant to be based on House
of M in the comics, and he's also supposed
to be visiting the 838 Universe
from Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness.
The rumor right now
is that they're actually just going to say
that the 838 universe winds up
turning into a house of M
Universe like after the events of Doctor
Strange Multiverse of madness.
838 Wanda is left in eventually winds up
using her chaos
magic powers to go full house of M
but more of a reverse house of them.
More of a situation
where she helps Magneto
who is going to be her father in the 838
universe completely take over that reality
So it's not exactly how that
and went down in the comics.
But if you hear people saying
that they're going to
do house of Them in Deadpool three, that's
what they're referring to a universe
like the 838 universe where Magneto
winds up taking over the entire planet
and mutants reign supreme.
but it's all meant to be happening
as a consequence
of what happened at the end of Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness.
So they're just carrying the plot
of that universe forward.
this is the main version of Wolverine
that Deadpool finds in the movie.
He finds him in that 838
House of M Universe and eventually
wins him over to his side, mostly
by wearing him down. As you can see.
Like they start the story in the movie
together with Wolverine
trying to claws face off
it looks like
they both get pruned together by the TVA
and sent to the Void planet
from the Loki series.
In the fight it drags on for so long
because they have healing powers.
Eventually Wolverine
just gets tired of all like,
Fine, whatever you can even see him
throwing deadpool's
severed arm back at him
as he crashes through the 20th Century
Fox logo, like the 20th Century Fox logo
got pruned in some alternate universe,
which is a bit of a Easter egg
for Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe,
but it's Deadpool
kills the Fox Marvel universe.
so in the eighth create
House of M Universe, Elizabeth Olsen
Scarlet Witch is supposed to be
Ian McKellen Magneto's daughter.
Oh, I'm going to go with Sir Ian McKellen.
I don't know if they're saying
that she's biologically his daughter,
along with Quicksilver in the comics,
or if they'll just say that
he thinks of her as his daughter
and wants to protect her from everyone
else is trying to get revenge on her.
all the surviving members
of the Illuminati that we didn't see
during Doctor Strange to want some revenge
Either way,
that universe is version of Magneto with
Ian McKellen coming back is protecting her
from all the other heroes like the X-Men,
Fantastic Four, all the Fox
Marvel characters that we know they're
bringing back from the older movies
because it is a bit of a swansong
for their characters, like Come and cameo.
one of the main classic X-Men.
The Bringing Back is Famke Janssen's
version of Jean Grey, who will get to go
full Phoenix again, this time
looking a little more comic book.
Remember,
this is the eight eight universe
and we're doing a house of inspired story.
That's how we got the Wolverine
Yellow costumed.
Like in this universe,
Professor X was a version based
closer to the X-Men
Animated Series version of the character.
So all the characters will be wearing
comic book costumes
that are closer to the original comics.
And it seems like at some point
during the movie
they'll build up to a giant battle
and it'll be kind of like X-Men three
Last Stand, only with everybody
trying to get Scarlet Witch instead of it
being Phoenix in it's
during this big final fight
that we'll get our Scarlet Witch
versus Phoenix fight.
so the big question
that everybody's been wondering
about for a long time,
who is more powerful?
Who would win in a fight?
Both characters are meant to be strong,
like some of the most powerful characters
in the Marvel Universe next to cosmic
beings, actual gods,
the one above all, like the one true God.
Franklin Richards.
The Beyond was God, Emperor Doom
Thanos with the full Infinity gantlet.
Surprisingly, there haven't been that
many Scarlet Witch versus Phoenix
fights in the comics and there haven't
been any fights like this before.
The last time Scarlet Witch fought Phoenix,
it was actually Scarlet Witch
versus Cyclops
when the Phoenix Force had split
and inhabited
multiple characters at the same time.
And she took him down quite easily.
But he was only wielding a portion
of the Phoenix's power.
And it was meant to be a big house of M
reference this was years ago in the comics
but the way she took down black bolt in
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness
was very similar,
taking them down with a whisper
when she was fighting Cyclops
with the Phoenix Force, she whispered
no more Phoenix
and used her reality warping powers
to get rid of the portion of the Phoenix
in his body.
the problem with this trick is that
she's not powerful enough to pull that
on the full Jean Grey Phoenix
when she's using 100%
of the Phoenix's power just explain
how each of their powers work.
Scarlet Witch already has magic
mutant based powers,
and she's already a mutant without her
chaos. Magic.
The chaos. Magic doesn't make her
a mutant.
It's only meant to amplify
her natural abilities to cosmic level.
But even then, for instance,
warping reality.
He can only do that on a planetary scale.
She can't control the entire universe.
At the same time.
She can't control other universes.
For instance, during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Magic,
she had to use the Darkhold to take over
the mind of the other Scarlet Witch,
so she couldn't cross the barrier
physically between dimensions on her own.
while mind walking into the other version
of Scarlet Witch
she was able to use the chaos
magic inside 838 Wanda.
But that was about the limit of it.
She couldn't warp
the reality of that entire universe.
the other thing about her chaos magic,
is that it's granted to her by Katherine,
God of chaos.
She's not a God herself or the avatar of a
God to make a midnight reference.
When she was born,
Katherine gave her her chaos magic.
And he's manipulating her to help him
reenter the main Marvel universe.
But he still exists
as a completely separate entity.
he's one of the more powerful gods,
like he's one of the elder gods,
but he isn't inhabiting her body
when she's using chaos magic.
She doesn't become a god temporarily
or anything like that.
the difference with the Phoenix Force
is that Jean Grey or any other character
who becomes the Phoenix actually becomes
the God they're inhabited, like taken over
by the God themselves.
the Phoenix Force is immortal,
indestructible, an immutable
manifestation
of the prime universal force of life.
the way they characterize it
in the Marvel universe.
It's like the spark that ignites all of
creation in the flame that consumes it.
so for instance, it's
kind of like the Big Bang itself.
the c r worship.
It is a God and believe
that it's the sister of their two
other gods who also pre-date the creation
of the universe.
But the other gods are really just
pretending that they created the universe.
there are a lot of gods
in the Marvel Universe that pretend
like they're the ones that are responsible
for all the really major things
that happen.
just to give you an idea of the power
scaling, though, like this God
tier power scaling one time the sheer gods
decided to destroy the entire universe,
and they called on the Phoenix
to actually be able to pull it off.
Like, okay, Phoenix
you destroy the universe.
Now that's how powerful
the Phoenix Force is.
It can affect reality
on a universal scale.
In the white crowned
version of the Phoenix, can also control
all the other Phoenix forces
in every other universe
without the need of something
like the Darkhold,
That version of the Phoenix
is meant to be nigh omnipotent.
Even the living Tribunal,
which is a multiversal
being is afraid of her in this form.
So if you want to get technical
about who's more powerful,
if we're talking about
the most powerful version of Scarlet Witch
versus
the most powerful version of the Phoenix,
then the Phoenix would be more powerful.
Now, a lot of you are also wondering
what would happen if Scarlet Witch became
the host of the Phoenix Force?
Wouldn't that be like the most top tier
character ever?
Technically, the one above all would
probably still be more powerful than them.
Maybe the Beyond was as well, just because
of the way they classified their powers.
They never actually done that
in the comics, though.
But theoretically, it's possible,
the way they've talked
about the Phoenix Force and Chaos Magic
Scarlet Witch is more of a yin yang
relationship
two very extremely powerful cosmic forces.
But. Early theory in Deadpool 3.
If they're going to be doing a version of,
say, like X-Men
the last stands final fight with everybody
coming out for Phoenix
only it's Scarlet Witch.
Instead that they're trying to take down
what will probably wind up happening
is that they'll pull a Vin Diesel versus
the rock.
Like you have a situation
where you have two incredibly popular,
very powerful characters.
how do you end the fight
before one of them
is actually declared the victor?
so if they're actually going
to riff on the end of X-Men
The Last Stand like a more comic book
version of that in the 88 universe, but
based more on House of M type of reality,
they might just wind up using something
like the mutant cure, like some big twist
like that to Dee Power 838 Wanda
And then just end the fight that way
let me know, though.
They have a whole bunch of Fox
Marvel cameos in the movie
and you have Phoenix
going up against Scarlet Witch.
Who do you actually want them to kill off?
Like the Pie will be some hilarious death
during the movie this is Comic-Con week.
And even though Marvel
isn't doing a big Hall
H panel, DC isn't doing their big hall
H panel,
they'll still be a bunch of big stuff
dropping in the next couple of weeks.
I'll do videos for everything,
and we're still in the middle
of our last couple of secret Invasion
episodes, so.
Be sure to enable alert for my channel.
So you don't miss any of those.
My full Secret Invasion
Episode five video will post on Wednesday.
Just like normal.
click here for that video
or update the link as soon as I post it
and click here for that brand new Deadpool
3 Wolverine versus Deadpool Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
I'll see you guys in the next one!